[Música]
we are one que significa agua y agua no
todos somos uno independientemente de
sus creencias religiosas color de piel
creencias políticas culturales clase
social género todos somos uno
es para
acabar con el odio la división
es una campaña de amor es una campaña de
paz
todos somos uno el bullyng este es uno
de los temas que más preocupantes para
todos yo creo que todos hemos estado en
una situación donde nos hemos sentido
peleados el bullying no nada más existe
en las escuelas sino en todos los
ámbitos en todas las edades trabajos
escuelas universidades
todos los países incluso yo creo que yo
me he sentido juliana en muchas
ocasiones
y
yo creo que es hasta que te pasa por
primera vez
qué empiezas a darte cuenta de cómo hay
tanto odio en el mundo la primera vez
que yo me sentí rechazada yo está en la
secundaria
y yo venía de una casa de mucho amor
todo era perfecto y todo bien y la
primera vez que me han excluido que no
me han invitado a la llamada o que me
hacían un lado mis amigas que fueron las
mismas amigas desde la primaria y tengan
en cuenta que en esa edad toda tu vida
es esa primaria esa esa secundaria se te
viene el mundo abajo
yo iba a la escuela siempre con dolores
de estómago nerviosa no quería aliviar y
siempre pensar decía que ya se acabe
esta etapa yo quiero que se acabe la
secundaria
pero yo como reaccione mucho tiempo
reaccione enojada tenía sentimientos
negativos con personas que me han hecho
las maldades pero un día al final ya
casi de terminar la secundaria respondí
con amor dije estas personas me hicieron
fuerte tolerante me enseñaron a quererme
a mí misma y no tener que cambiar
observo rega de ninguna para que me
aceptaran
me empecé a decir bueno es mejor
calidad que cantidad voy a estar con
gente alrededor
que me quieran tal y como soy a estar
con personas que no me acepten que me
rechacen
yo creo que todos nos hemos sentido
boleados en algún punto pero acuérdense
que el que más ruido hace es el más
débil
si alguien está tratando de lastimar
de hacer un lado de rechazar es por algo
déjalos a los un lado
nunca dudes de ti mismo porque el
bullying tiene consecuencias graves a
muchas personas han resultado en
ansiedad en depresión incluso estas en
suicidios entonces que querernos
respetarnos a aceptar a los demás
discapacidad
discapacidad es una dificultad física o
mental yo estudié psicología lo cual
hice muchas prácticas con personas con
discapacidad y uno de los problemas más
graves de ellos es que todos los días
ellos están luchando una batalla una
batalla que nosotros no sabemos por lo
que ellos están pasando
y aparte de eso no será aceptado dentro
de un grupo sociedad o una escuela
nelson mandela una vez dijo nosotros no
nacimos odiando discriminando haciendo
un lado a los demás
criticando nos enseñaron o lo vimos
entonces si podemos aprender a amar
hay que también aceptar
diversidad cultural
diversidad cultural es un tema que a mí
me pone muy sensible porque yo creo que
todos deberíamos ser orgullosos de dónde
venimos estas lenguas nuestra forma de
decir nuestros idiomas nuestra historia
tradiciones costumbres
y no hay que discriminar a otros por sus
formas de ser yo vengo de una casa donde
mi papá era kurdo o musulmán mi mamá
mexicana católica entonces diario veía
idiomas tradiciones formas de vestir
diferentes y tengo tantos recuerdos
buenos como también malos
donde me han discriminado por eso donde
he ido a la escuela y evitado decir que
mi papá es musulmán por miedo a que
alguien me critique o me rechace cree
que sentirnos orgullosos los pueblos
indígenas son los que indígenas son los
que nos hacen ricos en historia y en
país todos los países son ricos en
historia pero es su historia que lo hace
ricos
mi fundación tenemos un libro que enseña
inglés y una de las ediciones para
personas
en el idioma purépecha es una comunidad
indígena y yo siempre trato de decirle a
todos que va viajes todos los días que
prendan la tele 10 minutos de noticias
leer algo nuevo de otro país de otra
cultura
de conocer a una persona de otro estado
de otro país de otra creencia
de otra comunidad y preguntar no te
cierres se nota cuando una persona que
juzga y es cerrada es porque no ha
viajado no estudiado no se ha cultivado
lo suficiente porque cuando tienes
amistades de diferentes lados y
diferentes maneras de pensar y de ser no
eres tan fácil de juzgar uno fácil juzga
hasta que le pasa el mismo
esta persona indígena que me ayudó a
escribir este libro le preguntaba de
todo
cómo es tu comida a ver me regaló sus
vestidos me enseñó dónde vivían sus
formas de levantarse todos los días tan
diferentes a las nuestras pero
lamentablemente me platicó como han
también sido segregados
rechazados no han tenido las mismas
oportunidades que otros
aprendamos a respetar y apoyar a todos
por igual
igualdad de género
qué triste que todavía hoy en día veamos
estas las injusticias
lo único que buscamos son los mismos
beneficios los hombres y las mujeres
a mí me ha pasado muchas veces que me
hice en hannah tú no porque eres mujer
johana no mejor no uno tú no puedes no
eres muy sensible turno no gana
dame una oportunidad no me subestimen te
lo sabes
tengo la misma preparación igual que tú
tengo la misma capacidad pero yo que me
encontrado también en otras partes
donde no he querido tomar la palabra
otras culturas otras maneras de pensar
por ser mujer
en hace poco estuve en un país
extranjero donde estaba manejando un
auto y atrás de mi me chocó otro auto y
cuando me bajé para muy calmada yo me
bajé para ver qué se podía hacer la
persona me dijo no voy a hablar con una
mujer
ok
de regreso y me fui y también en muchas
ocasiones donde no he podido estar
sentada en el mismo lugar que hombres o
no te ven a los ojos
lo único que queremos es igualdad yo
creo que ya es momento de
orientación sexual qué triste que el
2019 la discriminación
discriminación
porque muchos de mis mejores amigos y
las personas que más quiero se han
sentido que no pueden ser ellos mismos
por miedo a ser discriminados y
rechazados e insultados
lastimados físicamente emocionalmente
malas palabras
hace un año uno de mis más cercanos
amigos me dijo le tengo que decir a mis
papás porque ya estoy cansado vivir en
una prisión donde no puedo ser yo mismo
te imaginas que seas discriminado por un
gesto por algo romántico por algo que
quién eres
y por vivir una sociedad donde nos
aceptada no puede hacer tú mismo
un sentimiento
mi mejor amigo se tuvo que ir de la
ciudad de mexico me dijo mi familia me
echó de la casa y ya no me quiere volver
a ver dicen que ya no son subir su hijo
y se tuvo que ir a una ciudad donde
fuera un poco más abierto al tema y yo
le dije no se vale
y él estaba cansado de actuar de una
forma ante las amistades de sus papás y
de la sociedad
puntos de vistas políticas yo estuve
seis años en la política
de diferentes cargos políticos
responsabilidades diferentes mis causas
son través también por un poco
controversial es para muchos el apoyar a
migrantes el apoyo de refugiados está
mucha gente lo mejor no le puede parecer
pero hay que respetar los puntos de
vista diferentes
si yo quiero apoyar una causa y la
apoyaba siempre tenía tres ataques sin
su apoyo a una caravana o yo tenía ganas
de apoyar la educación siempre había
alguien que no pensaba igual y está bien
uy qué no le grite decir todos vamos a
estar de acuerdo en estar en desacuerdo
nada más que con respeto
religión
[Música]
yo creo que todas las religiones pueden
yo puedo decir que pretenden abonar un
bienestar y paz
aunque muchas personas
perdieron la vida por sus creencias
muchas generaciones han sufrido
han ocultado en quién creen han perdido
su fe por eso yo digo porque no todos
podemos creer como queramos creer
mi mejor amiga judía mis amigos de
diferentes budistas cristianos
musulmanes
todos los años de mi papá son musulmanes
están en ramadán yo lo respeto y ellos
me respetan y no nada más lo respeto me
gusta escuchar cuáles son las formas
diferentes de ellos de vivir los
acompaño a veces a sus casas
espirituales y también me siento ahí
también rezó con ellos porque para mí
hay un dios aunque cada quien crea
diferente no hay por qué haya tanta
guerra y odio
hoy en día
por tu fe ya es momento de que todos
podamos respetar en quien creamos y como
queremos creerlo
estatus socioeconómico
cuántas veces han escuchado les han
dicho tú quién eres botella más
pedidas
cómo se llama tu papá
de qué escuela vienes de qué club de qué
empresa
de qué dueña de qué
quién es tu padrino
a quien conoces
me juzgan sin conocerme no me quieren
conocer antes de saber todo eso a qué me
dedico
al amor que me gusta hacer
antes de ser juzgada por tal vez un
apellido o un club
pero tristemente cuantas gracias somos
juzgados lo pueden ver en made in méxico
sin conocerme me juzgaron
lo puedes ver en todas las áreas de
secundaria ya fui rechazada
en la política cuanta grilla también
viví tienen el siguiente defiende quien
te apoya yo nada más soy jana
y eso es suficiente no tienes por qué
comprobar nada a nadie y hay que aceptar
nos tal y como somos sin etiquetas
diversidad de color de piel
lamentablemente el racismo todavía hoy
en día influye muchísimo y yo creo que
nosotros como mexicanos todos
seguramente tenemos una experiencia al
menos yo sí
a mí me han juzgado por ser mexicana por
ser kurda por mi tono de piel por como
hablo por racismo existe y lo triste es
que cuantas generaciones más van a
sufrir las
fui un one campaign es una campaña de
amor de paz es un cambio cultural porque
podemos tener leyes cambia el presidente
cada seis meses a cada seis años
cappa cambian de políticos pero lo que
necesitamos es un cambio cultural que
cada generación sea mejor que la pasada
que les demos herramientas a nuestros
hijos a nuestros nietos y que ellos a
los hijos de ellos para que cada
generación
pasemos seamos más unidos más en paz más
respetuosos más aceptados
por qué tanto odio porque muros por qué
restricciones quien nos enseñó a ser así
yo crecí en una familia con tanta
diversidad y ya que salía el mundo
mis papás me dejaron déjame soltarla y
volé vi tantas divisiones
por qué
he sido discriminada muchas veces porque
todos goleados y por alguno de estos
temas tal vez o tal vez no tal vez otras
pero el punto es que esto es una campaña
de amor y es una campaña de paz y meta
nada más con esta campaña es que podamos
ser un poquito cada generación un mundo
mejor con armonía amor y paz cuya buena
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i